[Music]
welcome to Frank's place Fox Meadows
preeminent gaming Resort Casino as Bob
remember this is an underground casino
we can't park outside my house or
everyone will know
Park it tailors take the path through
the woods boo you're right in my
backyard what's the password Andre the
Giant welcome we've got the relaxation
zone massage shiatsu deep tissue and
hand jobs hungry talked to Vinny in the
kitchen
he'll rustle you up an egg white omelet
that'll knock your socks off what the
hell is that
Craig weird eggs over-medium look at the
yolks that's not over medium take it
back right dick face you're doing a
great job hey hey welcome to club booze
because what does every casino need but
a kick-ass pool I'm that kid magnus de
magnum we have old is he 11 he's a
fantastic DJ this is a place for friends
hang out have fun get a rubdown get a
rub out and lose money am I in the
Bellagio or am i three blocks from my
house I genuinely don't know you know
what [ __ ] book club [ __ ] book club
Snake Eyes phrase place is legal adult
entertainment stablishment operating a
violation of several state and federal
statute Frank is not responsible
financial losses drug overdoses food
poisoning broken bones dismemberment
inhalation divorce arrest or
incarceration come to think of it a
legal disclaimer for an illegal casino
does make any sense we don't even know
why we're telling you this
you gotta move what are you doing you
got to move it Dana [ __ ] let's do it
again the house we do our June 30th
you
[Music]